à quels choix de se retrouver au milieu
de ses amis
casimir qu'est ce que tu as bonjour je
dis ça allait quasiment 10 mois est ce
que je rêve ou bien est-ce que tu as
perdu quelques kilos
il me semble que tu es moi enfin disons
plus minces ah ben c'est peut-être parce
que je viens de courir en france de plus
de 4 kilos mais françois jean todt
casimir a couru pendant quatre
kilomètres mais j'ai d'extraordinaire
casimir et tu as fait ça pour maigrir
bravo nous n'aurons pas du tout non a
lancé pour se préparer à manger un
gloubi boulga geo
bonjour je n'y ai même pas pensé alors
peut-être en train de tuer la course à
pied pour battre monsieur lisnard au jeu
moment complètement de monsieur du snob
mais alors qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya
quand je suis poursuivi
donc je me sauvais poursuivi mais mes
parties casimir soyez là voilà on va
retrouver voilà la réponse
mademoiselle futile évidemment soyez
gentil fantôme et là le plus longtemps
possible je suis épuisée par binômes ont
bataillé vraiment folle à plus tard
bonjour chers mais moi ça fait plaisir
de voir quelque chose d'important à dire
un quasi jamais reposée vous me bats
pour val d'oise et le couple est toute
essoufflée mais oui il n'est pas si
grande vous allez retrouver casimir je
vous apprends quelque chose à boire
volontiers j'ai un ballon qui se
dégonfle
qu'est ce que vous voulez boire et bien
je prendrais bien un peu de limonade
petit malade pourquoi cherchez-vous
casimir avec tant d'insistance au je ne
sais pas comment vous dire
c'est très embarrassant j'espère que ce
n'est pas grave
parler sans crainte nous sommes des amis
buvez ça vous donnera du courage
bon et bien voilà j'ai un problème pour
le cachet besoins des connaissances de
casini connaissance de casimir
absolument il sait tout
vous êtes sûr de ne pas faire erreur sur
la personne enfin vêtements s'il y aura
oui il m'a déjà d'ailleurs et aider pour
des problèmes de feuilles et de fruits
d'une façon tout à fait remarquable oui
il est vrai que casimir a des
connaissances immense mais si vous avez
besoin dead problèmes graves et urgents
peut être pourriez vous faire appel à
ses adjoints
pourquoi casimir à des adjoints au
parfait mais pouvons-nous les rassembler
certainement c'est très facile ce sont
les enfants de livres ils ont tant donné
mademoiselle futé a besoin de vous ça
alors il tombe un jeu sans moi
il faut absolument que je trouve un
moyen de te faire partir mademoiselle
futile pour retrouver mes amis j'ai une
idée
alors chère mademoiselle de quoi
s'agit-il
et bien voilà j'ai là quelques dessins
d'arbres dont j'ai oublié le nom mais
montrer des mollets les enfants vont
vous aider
les ensembles regardez cet arbre c'est
pas un sol très bien c'est un palmier
c'est un palmier et mademoiselle futech
et cet arbre boulot très bien c'est un
boulot avec centre blanc c'est un boulot
mademoiselle futé les enfants vous
apprennent beaucoup de choses c'est pas
ça pince et un peuplier sont très forts
et celui ci les enfants survivants
normal c'est un soul ploemeur ici
parfaitement pleure c'est un sapin et
celui ci a promis c'est pas rien c'est
un peu pour la mademoiselle papa c'est
un thuya
[Musique]
c'est ainsi près et bien voilà
mademoiselle vous savez tout ce que vous
vouliez savoir c'est parfait merci
françois françois reçoit un monstre
horrible
kevin
la mairie nous mais c'est vrai qu'il est
terrifiant et coordonnée savons-nous
vite vite vite aller sauver vous plaît
mais ça ne va pas du tout et je voulais
faire fuir cette fuite et de malheurs et
comme mes amies reste c'est le contraire
ce combo
[Musique]